Hmm,
no,
the scandinavians have this idea that
the world is a tree.
And uh,
I'd been thinking about that a lot.
I think that the tree idea tree is
something that is grounded in,
in matter,
let's say.
And that reaches up to heaven in the
Scandinavian tree at the bottom.
There's quite a cool idea at the bottom
of that.
See,
this tree is constantly being not by
snakes.
You can sort of see the snakes at the
bottom and at the same time it's being
watered and the water makes the tree
grow at the same rate that the snakes no
on its roots.
So it's like a Yin Yang idea,
you know,
that there's continual chaotic
destruction and replacement at the basis
of whatever this process is.
But the tree seems to me to be a
representation,
not so much of.
It's like a different dimensional space.
That's what's trying to be represented.
So imagine that you know,
you're structured.
If you take powers of 10 magnification,
say human beings are about in the middle
of the tiniest thing and the largest
thing if you do it by,
by powers of 10.
And so,
you know,
you have a sub atomic level and an
atomic level on a molecular level and
you know,
that,
uh,
that are maybe a level of organs and
then there's you and then there's your
family and so on,
all the way up the tree fundamentally.
And so I think that what this tree
represents,
and this is the things that thing that
the shaman moves up and down,
I think that's what it represents.
It's this,
it's this different view of,
of its dimensionality.
It's something like that.
And I think that what happens in the
psychedelic experiences that
consciousness can travel up and down
that structure.
It's something like that,
and maybe not only up and down it,
but maybe right through it.
I know that's a radical claim.
It's a really radical claim.
And if it might be wrong,
but it's probably wrong even because
most radical claims are wrong.
But,
but,
but I'm not so sure it's wrong.
Here's something cool.
So that's the Scandinavian world tree.
And that was drawn by an anthropologist
who visited the tribes in the Amazon who
use IOWASCA.
Now you see it's a snake.
It's a tree with snakes.
Well,
you know,
that's reminiscent of the story in Adam
and Eve obviously,
but it's also reminiscent of our primate
dwelling place,
right?
Because that was basically our ancestral
home,
a tree surrounded by snakes and the
snakes like to eat us and this is a long
time ago.
This is like
$50 million years ago.
It's really a long time ago and so we
don't know where these images come from
precisely,
but I do have the suspicion that
we use the circuitry that we developed
to detect snakes to represent the
unknown as such because like snake is
something that comes out of the unknown
and like we evolved,
right?
We all evolved out of an animal
substructure and so we had to get our,
our biological cognitive structure from
somewhere and we have this capacity of
thinking about the absolute unknown and
the terrors that are involved in that.
The horrors that can emerge from what we
don't understand and it stands
perfectly.
The reason that we would use circuits
that were already pre developed for that
and that this is a reasonable
representation of the existential
structure of the world.
So
I think I might've showed you this
before but
it never ceases to amaze me this,
this picture.
So my son drew this when he was nine,
eight and so on the right you see
mushroom houses and they have the names
of all his friends on them and so that's
order right?
And then on the left side you see chaos
there and that little orange thing is a
bug and then there's a river that runs
right down the middle and so that's like
the know the Yin Yang symbol with the
divide in the middle.
So that's quite cool.
And then there's,
there it is,
there's Jacob's ladder.
It's like Jack and the beanstalk,
which is by the way another variant of
the same shamonic story and there are
bugs going up and down it and then
they're taking messages from heaven and
then up there and haven't got the sun.
And there's St Peter and I don't know
where in the world he got this.
It's not like he had a lot of religious
education,
I mean read despite me.
Um,
and then,
oh,
there's the pearly gates up there and
then that was the world as far as his,
he had a very well ordered psyche I
would say.
And,
and still does,
but when he drew that,
it just absolutely blew me away.
And so I had it laminated and it's in my
office because,
well,
I don't know because like,
what the hell do you make of that?
You know,
that's,
that's why so,
well you sort of get the picture there,
you know,
the cathedral is the great cathedrals of
Europe or they're like the forest in
stone,
right?
And they try to represent the light
coming through the leaves and so it's
sort of our ancestral forest home,
but it's,
it's transformed into these great
sculptures of stone and you know,
they produce all because of the
combination of light and darkness and
color.
But also I think for the same reason
that huge trees produce art and people,
you know,
and we don't want them cut down.
They seem sacred in some sense.
And perhaps they are.
But
no,
and it also seemed to me this is an
intuition that the the architects of
these great cathedrals were trying to
get.
You're trying to express something
that's deep and structural.
They're trying try and try and to
express the idea that if being was
constituted properly,
then it would be organized from the
subatomic level all the way up to the
highest cosmic level perfectly,
so every layer stacked on top of each
other without any contradictions.
That would be an ideal mode of being and
everything would come together under
those circumstances.
And that's what's being expressed in
these cathedrals.
It's not all that's being expressed
because they're also shaped like a cross
and you know,
the idea is that the center of the
Cross,
which is the center of suffering,
is also the place of the individual.
The place where the transformation takes
place.
That's all built into the architecture
as well.
So
then there's the tree like structures
that make us up.
It's stretched down to the tiniest
realities,
the microcosm,
and there's this,
this idea,
it's all represented in the same way.
Again,
it's this idea,
especially the Mandela up in the top
right,
it's the idea of his perfection of
crystalline structure and that's what
the Yogis are trying to attain when they
organize their bodies.
They're trying to get every single layer
of there being aligned properly and it's
something like,
and you can kind of see an echo of that
in the.
I think that's a Tibetan sand painting,
if I remember correctly,
on the on the bottom left.
The idea is that if you get yourself
aligned properly,
then information can flow along that
tree,
that that's you without
without impediment,
something like that,
and that would be like a state of
optimal health and that both physical
and spiritual exercises can put you in
that state and that's while those are
all clouds of ideas that surround this
idea of a ladder to heaven.